كرمها مهرجان القاهره السينمائي في دوره
الرابعه والاربعين بجائزه فاتن حمامه
للتميز تقديرا لمسيرتها الفنيه المخرجه
المصريه كامله ابو ذكري في لقاء خاص لسي
انيم بالعربيه للحديث عن هذه المسيره التي
بداتها من السينما وقدمت خلالها اعمالا
تلفزيونيه ناجحه فالى ماذا تميل في هذه
المرحله
[موسيقى]
شهره وسيط ونجاح وحب ناس
وطلع مخزون كبير من جوايا بس الحقيقه انا
خرجت معهد السينما واشتغلت طول عمري
مساعده في السينما لكن ده بعد الثوره بعد
2011 حصل توقف في السينما خالص نهائيا
يعني
اضطرينا كلنا يعني مش انا لوحدي ك- مجموعه
كبيره من السينمائيين ومخرجين ممثلين
ومؤلفين
تصوير نتجه للتلفزيون لان السينما يعتبر
توقفت تمام نهائيا
فده
اعتقد انه صيد التلفزيون او المسلسل
المصري لانه الجيل ده عمل نقله لشكل
الصوره وشكل التكنيك والافكار وكل ده بس
في خطنا السينما انا نفسي ارجع على
السينما ثاني عشان اشوف هل انا عندي
القدره برده لسه على
اخراج الفيلم لانه انت لما تبقى هي بتحكي
الحدوته في 10 ساعات او في 15 ساعه غير
لما تحكيها في ساعتين اصعب كثير الساعتين
انا بحب السيما
وكنت اتمنى ان انا ابقى
اللي انا عملته في التلفزيون ده يعني انا
عملت مثلا خمس مسلسلات كله مسلسل ب 10
افلام كنت ابقى عامله 20 فيلم 30 فيلم
قدمتهم المخرجه كامله ابو ذكري خلال
مسيرتها الى جانب عملها في البدايه
كمساعده لمخرجين المصريين من ابرز صناع
السينما المصريه فما الذي تتمنى ان تقدمه
سينمائيا في هذه المرحله
وفضلت موجوده دي تجربه نفسي اتكلم عنها مش
مساله مها او ضد مساله ان انا اكتشف نفسي
واكتشف ايه اللي حصل انا شفت ايه همم في
ال 18 يوم اللي عندهم في الميدان واللي
كان كملوا لغايه يوم 30/6 يعني لغايه يوم
3/7 بعد لما عزلوا مرسي يعني انا قعدت
السنه دي تقريبا انا مش باشتغل انا قاعده
في الميدان يعني انا بالنسبه لي شغل ايه
وهمم بلدي
بتنهار يعني همم عندي شغل اقدمه وانا بلدي
في عدم امان وفي كل ده يعني املي اعمل
فيلم على فلسطين امليل
عن فلسطين عن عن فلسطين مش بتاعت
المهرجانات اللي بترضي الاذواق واللي
بترضي الميول فلسطين اللي انا عارفاها
حدوته اللي انا عارفاها وعارفه حقيقتها من
خلال ابويا
املي اتكلم عنهم لو قلت الحقيقه مش
هيقبلوه في مهرجانات الكبيره
مشتغلين عليه فبقت النهايه ان احنا
ابتدينا بثوره 52 ونهينا بثوره 25 يناير
همم فاحنا كنا قاصدين ال 60 سنه دول ان
احنا نحكي عنهم من خلال ذات نحكي على بلد
حصل فيها ايه التغيير السياسي والاقتصادي
والانساني والفني ولكل حاجه في 60 سنه دول
لكن بقيه المسلسلات همم
مش عارفه يمكن واحده الغروب انا كاتب
بالنسبه لي هي المرايه بتاعه 25 يناير
لانها كانت بتتكلم عن هو كان مؤمن جدا
بصوره اعرابي وكان واقف مع اعرابي وكده
وبعدين فجاه
تحول اي حد مؤمن بصوره عرابي بقى خائب بدل
ما اسمع ثوره بقى اسمها الهوجا كانت
ساعتها في واحده الغروب فكنت حاسه ان هي
مرايه ال 25 يناير المفاجاه الثوره تحولت
كل من قام بها هو خائن ده مش حقيقي خالص
اكيد في ناس خائنه ده مش مش او في ناس كان
لها مصالح ثانيه لكن اا فانا كان يعني
واخده الغروب
المفروض الاحداث كانت 1,000 وهمم
1885 كنت انا حاسه ان انا باتكلم عن 25
يناير لكن المسلسل بتلوعه الروح الذي
قدمته كامل لابو ذكري في موسم دراما رمضان
2022 كان اكثر من شهاده على مرحله بالنسبه
لها
واجب واجب علينا كلنا انه همم انه الواحد
يعرف الناس جزء من الحقيقه حتى لانه الروح
على فكره هو اا خمس الحقيقه الحقيقه اسوء
من كده بكثير لكن حقيقي وما كنتش اقدر
اعمل الحقيقه واضحه قوي كده لان هي ده
بيتعرض في التليفزيون وفي رمضان في مكانش
يبقى صعب على المشاهد ونشوف الدمويه
والقسوه دي اللي انا شفته من خلال تجربتي
بتحضير بطلوع الروح كلنا عارفين التنظيم
داعش وكلنا عارفين انه
تنظيم ارهابي وكذا وكذا وحاجات من بعيد
شفناها لكن الحقيقه لما انا دخلت جوه
المسلسل وابتديت اشوف حاجات كثير شوف
افلام
وثائقيه اقابل ناس من اهل الرقه عاشوا
التجربه وهربوا همم
وقابل حد كان اضطر يبقى من تنظيم داعش وهو
ولد عنده 15 16 سنه
فيحكي لي التجربه بتاعته وهربان منهم برده
انت بتهون لا لا لا لا ده الحقيقه مرعبه
الحقيقه مرعبه فواجب ان احنا نفهم الناس
انه انه انه انه انه ان ده مش الدين
مبدايا ده مش دينا ده مش الدين لانه مثلا
اول قبل ما المسلسل يظهر في ناس حمله كده
طلعت اللي هم ايه قطعوا المسلسل اللي
بيهاجم الدين الاسلامي او بيتكلم عن الدين
الاسلامي هو على فكره ده اسلامي انتم كفره
انتم مش بني ادمين اساسا انتم انتم الدين
انتم اللي خليته كلمه الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اه والله اكبر
انتم اللي خليته ممكن واحد اجنبي
لان هي بقت مقتنع
بالتفجير والذبح انت اللي لو وسط الدين
انت اللي انت اللي دوست شكلنا كله مش احنا